yeah and you have to start giving up  material unfortunately like okay to  Bishop B2  and eventually you'll have to give up  this this exchange like Queen H2  Bishop G2 and you have to take on B2  otherwise you get mated and you're  slightly worse in that end game but  you're probably not going to lose it  yeah Magnus wins  um  what was retrosy at the end of the game  ah exactly exactly what we said yeah  King takes F5 he played B3 of course  it's not  I mean you have to make small uh  more complicated tricks  yeah  okay 30 seconds for it's move 36 let's  stay with skill uh definitely very  exciting  let's see if he it's not an easy  decision because you feel the worst is  behind but actually not yeah you you  actually I mean you up I should have to  give up that exchange he will be  extremely upset about that because like  you're winning chances in that end game  up like exactly 0